[Music]
the first chapter of science in the soul
is called the values of science and the
science of values and it does of course
give prominence to objective truths
there is a kind of whispering campaign
more than whispering campaign sometimes
a yelling campaign against the value of
objective truths science I think is
committed to objective truth we're
committed to the view that if that is
the truth is independent of the cultural
background of the scientist for example
so I've said in the book an experiment
done in a lab in New York can be
replicated in a lab in New Delhi and if
it's all done correctly in the same way
they all get the same the same result
science has belief in objective truth
works engineering technology based upon
the science of objective truths achieves
results it manages to build planes that
get off the ground it manages to send
people to the moon and explore Mars with
robots and land robotic vehicles on
comets science works as produces
antibiotics it produces vaccines that
work so anybody who chooses to say oh
there's no such thing as objective truth
it's all subjective it's all socially
constructed tell that to a doctor tell
that to a space scientist manifestly
science works and the view that there is
no such thing as objective truth doesn't
science proceeds I believe in the sort
of riparian view that sounds proceeds by
intuitive leaps of the imagination
building an idea of what might be true
and then testing it by experiment by
observation in the second phase it's a
kind of Darwinian selection of mutation
which is provided by the imagination so
intuition is very important
but it is important that scientists
should not be so wedded to their
intuition that they that they omit the
very important testing phase and if the
hypothesis is disproved they should
regard that as as a reason to reject the
hypothesis or modified not a reason to
just carry on doggedly sticking to the
hypothesis because they are intuitively
committed to it
the phrase critical thinking is quite a
cliche but it is immensely important and
so I think that I really could sum it up
by saying what we need is critical
thinking we need to respect evidence we
need to respect the fact that the only
reason to believe anything about the
real world
is evidence the evidence must be
assessed critically preferably
statistically and logically you cannot
derive truths about the real world by
intuition alone by feelings alone by
what feels good people who say things
like all opinions are equally valid or
well it's true for me it may not be true
for you never never tolerate that kind
of thing the only reason to believe
anything is true is that there's
evidence and everybody should either
look at the evidence for themselves or
they should trust that the person
they're talking to has looked at the
evidence in a scientific logical
rational critical way even if midrib
just for example I I'm not qualified to
assess the evidence of modern physics
experiments and just not qualified so I
have to trust Noah this is not trusting
authorities so much as trusting the
scientific method which I know has been
used by physicists whom I can't directly
assess it's been used by physicists who
are using the same techniques as I know
work in my own field of of biology
[Music]